this new trailer shucks okay so fake out
opening but stick with me here so what I
actually want to talk about is something
that is an argument i see get made every
now again and i seen it quite recently
in regard to a fair number of comments
that showed up on my last ghost in the
shell related video and that is people
telling me you can't judge a movie just
by the trailer wait until you see it and
basically there's always somebody who
comes out of the woodwork to tell me
that whenever i declare i don't intend
to see this movie based on a piece of
marketing people said that when i
declared that i wasn't going to go to
wonder woman they've now done something
ghost in the shell and you know any time
I say this makes me not want to watch
the movie there's always somebody who
says stop judging by the trailer and
which i spose on the one hand i get
where that's coming from because it's
like it's an extension of don't judge a
book by it's cover but can we actually
examine that sentiment for a second the
entire point of the trailer is for it to
be judged the reason it exists is so
that the studio can make you aware that
the film exists here is a sampling of it
here is the feel of it here's the vibe
of it please judge this we hope you
judge that you will want to now see the
movie the entire purpose of marketing
and so you will judge it they hope
positively however whenever I judge
something that positively the defenders
of it are the people who don't share my
criticisms or whatever which is fine you
don't have to agree with me but to say
you can't judge it by the trailers that
is why is here now if I'm being fair
because I know people are going to bring
this up there are times that trailers
are misleading for one reason or another
maybe the people doing the marketing end
of it don't understand the movie maybe
there's just something about the movie
that's really hard to market so there's
sort of putting it and putting emphasis
on a different angle that isn't
necessary the representative of the
whole film I know that happens on
occasion and you can sign the examples
but first of all the times does that
happen is the minority of the time and
sytan well most of the really egregious
examples you can find if misleading
trailers are not on
releases their on mid budget films or
they're on low-budget films being
distributed by a higher-end studio on
some level and I've also noticed the
opposite almost never happens I see
trailer and go wow I'm really excited
about this it's pretty much never
happens when somebody goes you shouldn't
judge me by the trailer it could suck
which I actually think would be a much
more interesting conversation to have
because I think it's much more
interesting when they make a really good
trailer to a bad movie I mean we don't
even have to look that far in the past
Prometheus had amazing trailer Suicide
Squad my god those trailers were awesome
I would happily watch those trailers
again I don't ever want to see the movie
again but can anyone really think of too
many examples of the other ahead of
big-budget tentpole film that had lousy
trailers but turned out to be really
good I can't think of any off the top of
my head not in recent years at any rate
and I know that might sound like a
cop-out to say you know like in the last
five six years or whatever but I mean
the nature of trailers and how trailers
are constructed in what passes for you
know being good way to sell it keeps
changing I mean go go back and look at a
trailer from the early two thousands
from the 90s from the 80s actually that
we have fun experiment just pick a
decade and take them pick a well-known
movie look at the trailer from that
decade see how much trailers have
changed but I digress now the other
thing is that people and again this has
come up with ghosts Michelle people have
been like well you know maybe they're
holding things back and maybe it's this
and it could be this and they could be
you trying to trick you and that's
possible but here's the thing unless I'm
dealing with JJ Abrams who does and has
flat out wide even what he's talked
about Adlene the lead-up to films and
with his trailers um I am gonna take
what they give me at face value it just
strikes me as a really bizarre bit of
blind hope to see a trailer and then go
oh well I bet is really about this thing
that I lied to be about even the trailer
doesn't indicate that in any way
whatsoever that's a spec so we're
reaction to me now to be fair how much
weight you want to give to a trailer
maybe should vary on a case-by-case
basis I think specifically in terms of
genres I think
sums on Rah's are it's much more fair to
judge it very substantially on the TRO
than others so I'll sort of pick the two
extremes to exemplify what I'm talking
about I think it is incredibly fair to
judge the hell out of a comedy by its
trailer because the very simple measure
did the trailer make you laugh then the
movie might make you laugh if you didn't
laugh at the trailer which theoretically
is some of the best parts to hook you in
you're probably not going to laugh at
the rest of the movie on the flipside
horror is really hard to cut a good
trailer for because most of the really
effective horror movies regardless of
the sub-genre whether it's a ghost movie
or as a slasher or whatever depend
heavily on a sense of atmosphere and a
buildup of dread and sort of really
specific circumstances in a shot how
long it lingers before stuff happens and
it's all stuff that takes time and when
you cut together a trailer with these be
quick and punchy they just end up
jumping between jump scares or bake
shadows and pretty much almost all
horror trailers look the same regardless
of the actual finished product so i
would say that and that is a genre that
if you wanted to tell me don't judge it
by the trailer i would go you know what
that's fair because it's almost
impossible to properly sell a horror
movie based on the trailer all you can
really do is explain the premise and
that is not the same as giving you a
feel of the atmosphere or whether or not
there's a sense of dread in the thing at
all i suppose this is just my
long-winded way of saying guys stop
telling me not to judge a movie by the
trailer and decide whether or not i'm
going to see it based on the trailer
that's why it exists so i'm going to
judge it and if it is found wanting i
will judge it rather harshly so that's
it for this one guys don't forget to
like subscribe check me out on twitter
at council of geeks give a listen to
counseling geek podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
you
[Applause]